each state's respective coefficient and the normalization condition 2 n minus one can generally be approached by
initializing the state with the operator o the starting state would be the all zero standard basis state often written
like this for simplification in general this requires an exponential number of C not gates often times We are
interested in a specific initial state for the system and its preparation can be implemented with a reasonable amount
of resources. Product states for example in which the cubits are not entangled with each other only require single
cubit operations. Now we haven't actually had the opportunity to talk about trotterization
yet though some of you are probably already familiar with it. In essence, trotterization is a method for calculating matrix exponentiation that
uses approximations to handle the exponential nature of non-communive operators. When two operators like HA
and HB don't commute, then we must supply a clever trick and alternatively apply the corresponding exponentials of
eus i ha and eus i hb for n number of
times. the alternating evolution operators are applied. I won't go over the proof here, but I will share a link
to a nice simple proof of this statement in the description. But the take-home message is this. Time evolution is an
important part of mapping too. Trotterization breaks up a continuous interaction into discrete steps that can
be implemented on a quantum computer. After generating the trotterized circuit, we have finally finished the
mapping step. We can now move on to circuit optimization.
To do that, this is what needs to be accomplished. There needs to be a cubit layout that maps the virtual cubits of
your circuit to physical ones on the hardware. This is needed because hardware can have particular topologies
which restrict the direct interaction of physical cubits. While implementation of
a quantum circuit often assumes the ability for any cubit to interact with any other cubit. Then we need to insert
swap gates as needed to route interactions between cubits that are not connected. We need to translate the
gates in our circuit to instruction set architecture or ISA instructions that
can directly be executed on the hardware. Then we need to perform circuit optimizations to minimize the
circuit depth and gate count. This step can also be performed on the virtual circuit. The circuit where the cubits
have not yet been mapped to a device topology yet. But remember much of this is done automatically for you in
Qiskit. We will see exactly how in the next section of this lecture. After the optimization step, we are ready to run
the circuit using a primitive. For most simulation experiments, you are interested in understanding the change
of certain properties of the system with time. So it's likely you will be using the estimator primitive because that
will let you measure the expectation values of observables corresponding to specific properties. Then we will
configure the best options for the estimator which can add error suppression and error mitigation techniques. Finally, we will run the
experiment. The last step is to post-process all the data. This extracts the measured expectation values or if
you're using the sampler, the sample probability distribution in the computational basis. If all one needs
are the expectation values of the observables of interest, these can be directly obtained from the estimator
primitive both in their raw and error mitigated values. Often times one will then use the measured expectation values
for other calculations for other quantities of interest which don't require quantum computation and can be
computed on a classical computer.
Now we are going to walk through a real example from a very influential paper IBM published a couple years ago called
the evidence for utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance. Now this paper which we abbreviate fondly as
the utility paper became a very influential paper in the field of quantum computing almost immediately upon publication.
The overall thesis of the paper is that a noisy quantum computer produced accurate results or expectation values
using 127 cubits and 2,880 gates outside the capabilities of brute
force computation which is the exact simulation of the quantum circuits executed by the hardware. This work was
also important because it showed that a quantum computer could be used to verify or compare results with other
approximate classical methods for quantum simulations such as tensor network algorithms where the solution
was not known by priori. What is also rather cool is that now others using the IBM quantum systems on
the cloud and kiskuit can duplicate and verify these results themselves.
I'm going to walk you through how to do just that. So for this example, we will get a little bit more specific about the
steps involved in mapping this problem into inputs that can be understood by a quantum device. In this case, we will be
simulating the dynamics of the total magnetization of a system of magnetic dipole spins on a lattice in the
presence of an external magnetic field. The system can be described by an icing model with a transverse magnetic field.
We model this with a parameterized quantum circuit where the parameters correspond to the tunable value of the
spin spin or z interaction and the strength of the magnetic field X. Now,
this series is called quantum computing in practice. So, we're also going to discuss procedures in this experiment
that we're going to implement to make the results as good as possible. So next we are going to discuss how to remove
bad cubits or cubits with low gate fidelities or decoherence times which could drastically affect the
experimental outcomes. These bad cubits can occur due to poor prior calibration
or two-level systems interacting with the cubit. Removing some cubits from the hardware native topology corresponds to
considering a system on a lattice described by the resulting topology. We are also going to discuss creating the
parameterized quantum circuit which implements the time evolution of the system via trotterization.
For this purpose, it will be important to identify entangling layers which are a critical part for the main error
mitigation technique we are going to use later on. So at this point I want to make sure that you the audience know
that you can follow along with everything that I'm about to discuss in the tutorial linked below and on the IBM